we had the encyclopedia britannica at
home
and even when i was a small boy he used
to sit me
on his lap and read to me from the
encyclopedia britannica
and we would read say about dinosaurs
and maybe it would be talking about
the brontosaurus or something and he
would say something like or the
tyrannosaurus rex
and it would say something like this
thing is 25 feet high
and the head is six feet across you see
himself
and he'd so he'd stop always and say
let's see what that means
that would mean that if he stan stood in
our front yard he would be high enough
to put his head
through the window but not quite because
the head is all a little bit too wide it
would break
the window as it came by everything we'd
read
would be translated as best we could
into some
reality so that i learned to do that
that everything i read i tried to figure
out
what it really means what it's really
saying by translating
and so i used to get read the
encyclopedia
when i was a boy but with translation
you seen so
it was very exciting and interesting to
think that there was animals
of such magnitude i wasn't frightened
that there would be one coming in my
window as a
consequence of this i don't think but i
thought it was very very interesting and
that they all died out and at that time
nobody knew why
we used to go to the catskill mountains
we lived in new york and in the catskill
mountains is a place where
people went in the summer and the
fathers there was a big group of
people there but the fathers would all
go back to new york to work during the
week and only come back over in the
weekend
and on the weekends when my father came
he would take me for walks in the woods
and would tell me various things about
interesting things that were going on in
the woods which i'll explain in a minute
but
the other mothers seeing this of course
thought that was wonderful and that
their other father should take their
sons
for a walk so they tried to work on them
but they didn't get anywhere
at first and they wanted my father to
take all the kids but he didn't want to
because he had a special relationship to
me
we were a personal thing together
so it ended up that the other fathers
had to take their children for walks the
next
weekend and the next monday
when they were all back to work we were
all the kids were playing in the field
and then one kid said to me see that
bird what kind of a bird is that
and i said i haven't the slightest idea
what kind of a bird it is
he says it's a brown throat a throat and
thrush or something he says your father
doesn't tell you anything
but it was the opposite my father had
taught me looking at a bird he says
do you know what that bird is it's a
brown throated thrush
but in portuguese
he says in chinese in japanese
etc he says now they've know all the
languages you want to know what the name
of that bird is
and when you're finished with all that
he says you'll know absolutely nothing
whatever about the bird
you only know about humans in different
places and what they call the bird now
he says let's look at the bird and what
it's doing
he had taught me to notice things and
one day when i was playing with
what we call an express wagon which is a
little wagon which has a railing around
it
for children to play with that they can
pull around
it had a ball in it i remember this it
had a ball in it and i
pulled the wagon and i noticed something
about the way the ball moved
so i went to my father and i said say
pop
i noticed something when i pull the
wagon the ball rolls to the back of the
wagon it rushes to the back of the wagon
and when i'm pulling along and i
suddenly stop the ball rolls to the
front of the wagon i said why is that
and he said that he says nobody knows
he said the general principle is that
things that are moving try to keep on
moving
and things that are standing still tend
to stand still unless you push on him
hard
and he says this tendency is called
inertia but nobody knows why it's true
now that's a deep understanding he
doesn't give me a name he knew the
difference between knowing the name of
something
and knowing something
which i learned very very early he went
on to say
if you look close you'll find the ball
does not rush to the back of the wagon
but it's the back of the wagon that
you're pulling ta against the ball that
the ball stands still or as a matter of
fact from the friction starts to move
forward really
and doesn't move back so i ran back to
the little wagon
and set the ball up again and pulled the
wagon from under it and looking sideways
and seeing indeed he was right
the ball never moved backwards in the
wagon when i pulled the wagon forward
it moved backward relative to wagon but
relative to the sidewalk
it was moved forward a little bit it's
just the wagon caught up with it
so that's the way i was educated by my
father
with those kind of examples and
discussions
with no pressure just lovely interesting
discussions